this is Topol sorry I missed your call I
just got out of a briefing briefing was
there a buffet I can't tell you you
don't have the security clearance what
are you doing I wasn't invited to your
top-secret briefing so I've been
catching up on my telenovelas they're
addictive stop goofing off it makes me
look bad oh you sound grumpy supervisor
winters did you not sleep well actually
I had a rough night
go on someone changed the locks on my
apartment I had to sleep in my car oh
dear did you call your landlord I can't
get ahold of him you know I certainly
hope it's not because someone placed him
on a terrorist watch list and now he's
being flown out of the country with a
bag over his head you know just because
someone decided to mess with them
because someone has the ability to make
other people's lives miserable what are
you doing to me I'm neutralizing a
threat to national security I'm a threat
to national security
I work in national security and you're
threatening to me so you're neutralizing
me by making me sleep in my Jetta oh
that reminds me your jet has been towed
to the bottom of the Delaware River
I won't go call of duty on your ass I
will turn your life inside out
Oh with your computer hacking are you
gonna change the default font on my
email keep talking and see what
happens I'll see you burn in hell
I need to print out a memo 4wd chief
Rollins where can I get more printer
toner oh you should ask your new
boyfriend Deputy Chief Rollins I got to
get back to my show this family is loca
what family I was just clicking through
our global remote cam surveillance
matrix and they look like they'd be fun
to follow for a while oh I gotta go
I think Marlena and Raul are having an
affair that's a horrible I know
I sent an agent to have him taken care
of